voyons là que le terrorisme frappe tous
les pays frappent régulièrement et que
l'enjeu qui auxquels nous sommes
confrontés c'est de le réduire et pour
le réduire il n'y a qu'une solution
c'est la coopération internationale nous
le savons tous c'est cela la solution
passait mieux c'est à dire contre la
barbarie
c'est en tout cas indispensable nous
sommes entrés dans un processus qui est
maintenant qui dure depuis un certain
nombre d'années les événements qui se
succèdent dans différents pays sont la
démonstration qu'on est entré dans un
phénomène durable et face à ce phénomène
durable bien évident qu'il faut qu'il y
ait une coopération internationale et
que globalement les pays les pays
d'abord les pays démocratiques bien sûr
auquel nous sommes attachés prennent les
dispositions nécessaires sachant que
c'est une lutte qui est extrêmement
difficile sur alors vous dites renforcer
la coopération internationale notamment
en europe c'est ce que préconise
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui même le chef de
l'état mais il ya également le combat
jacques mézard à l'intérieur de nos
frontières comment faire face à la
radicalisation d'une partie de notre
jeunesse qui programment désormais la
mort d'autres jeunes
nous avons vu au cours de ces dernières
années
la diffusion de ces d'une idéologie de
destruction qui a été il faut bien le
dire aussi facilitée par ce qui se passe
c'est ce qui s'est passé au moyen-orient
qui a été facilité aussi par les réseaux
sociaux par les nouveaux modes de
transmission de la communication c'est
une c'est une réalité
là je pense d'ailleurs que nous serons
dans l'obligation de travailler sur ces
domaines là l'avantagé que nous avons
une part de responsabilité nous la
société dans son ensemble dans ses
dérives des djihadistes nés sur notre
sol cette idée a été émise dans la
campagne par emmanuel macron ou est-ce
qu'il faut s'interroger sur notre
responsabilité bien sûr qu'il ya une
responsabilité collective yagg
responsabilité internationale parce
qu'on s'est quand même qu'un certain
nombre d'actions en tout cas c'est ma
position et je les ai déjà énoncé à la
tribune du sénat
certaines actions des pays occidentaux
au moyen-orient qui n'ont pas facilité
les choses et dont on peut dire ce qui
s'est passé en irak ce qui s'est passé
ensuite en libye par exemple je ne pense
pas que ça ait pas eu peur que ça a été
très positive et apparemment le chef de
l'état qui n'était pas encore et évoqué
des difficultés d'intégration les ratés
dans les relations qui peuvent déboucher
sur ce genre de comportement bien sûr
qu'il ya des ratés de l'intégration et
que c'est une responsabilité collective
bon si nous ne sommes pas capables nous
de considérer que nous avons une part de
responsabilité dans la dérive d'une
partie de notre population et de nos
jeunes et dans un certain nombre de
quartiers ce serait dans un pas très
réaliste